hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update tony has just revealed some
new details on the PlayStation view
including its release date and price
according to Sony the cloud-based
PlayStation view will be available for
both ps4 and ps3 and will arrive on ipad
at a later date the news follows the
rollout of sling TV on Microsoft's Xbox
one with pricing that starts at twenty
dollars and charges five dollars for
additional bundle options the
PlayStation view service will offer more
than 85 channels at launch including CBS
hey that's us and three bundles to
choose from priced at fifty dollars
sixty dollars or seventy dollars NBC Fox
discovery Turner and Viacom are some of
the other currently listed channels with
AMC set to join the service roster
sometime after launch the cheapest
option access includes approximately 50
channels the core package adds local
sports channels and the elite package
adds lifestyle music and family channels
but all three have access to live TV and
the systems built in DVR like
functionality and like other
entertainment apps on playstation view
will not require a PlayStation Plus
subscription PlayStation view is
launching today but only in New York
Chicago and Philadelphia further cities
are going to be announced later this
year either way I don't pay for cable
now and that's a lot more than I'm gonna
pay for TV so this is probably the last
thing you're gonna hear about view on
gamespot for even more news stay tuned
to gamespot com / news